we all spend a good chunk of our time on
the internet every day be it watching
videos on YouTube or just browsing
social media as of 2022 69 of the
world's population uses the internet now
imagine if this invisible network of
data becomes something you can see and
interact with instead of just watching
your friends pictures on Instagram you
can interact with them in real time
instead of just watching through a
screen you can immerse yourself in that
environment for the most realism this is
where the metaverse comes in but what
even is the metaverse the term metaverse
was coined by writer Neil Stevenson in
his 1992 science fiction novel snow
crash Stevenson described the metaverse
in his novel as a vast Digital Universe
that exists alongside the actual world
the metaverse is a virtual reality
environment where users can communicate
with a computer-generated environment
and other participants in the long run
it will essentially act as a 3D version
of the internet
furthermore Mark Zuckerberg the CEO of
meta predicts that the core elements of
the metaverse will take five to ten
years to become mainstream however the
metaverse is rapidly expanding you can
see those Ultra fast internet
connections virtual reality headgear and
permanent always-on online worlds are
already operational if you currently own
any cryptocurrency virtual reality
Hardware or even an nft you are already
a part of the metaverse
although the metaverse is significantly
more vast than a video game it appears
that the gaming world has already
embraced it consider the online game
fortnite in which users have a
personalized Avatar with which they
connect and interact amongst themselves
while also collecting virtual currency
to buy costumes and upgrades for their
Avatar according to Engineers the
metaverse will Elevate the virtual
reality experience to a new level
allowing players to float into the
virtual environment to do anything from
buying land and hosting parties to even
getting married using digital avatars
the metaverse is being developed further
using mixed reality technology which
blends VR which stands for virtual
reality and AR meaning augmented reality
with the elements of touch and smell
being a part of the metaverse experience
the immersion is further enhanced by
haptic feedback which provides
vibrations for certain actions the
concept of the metaverse has greatly
benefited from the introduction of VR
devices like Oculus and HTC Vive games
made specifically for VR headsets are
already extremely profitable AR takes
this a step further by using technology
to improve the user's sense of reality
but how will the metaverse provide an
upgrade over the current Internet from
an application standpoint the ability to
interact physically with people
thousands of miles away without
investing in travel costs will benefit
both personal and professional
conditions students in schools can put
their wild ideas to the test without
having to subject themselves to the
risks associated with certain materials
allowing medical professionals to assist
or even perform surgeries from the other
end of the world will be a life-saving
benefit
the digital economy is also strengthened
by introducing cryptocurrency and nfts
in the metaverse
similar-minded individuals can connect
in the metaverse and exchange thoughts
about each other's growth and prosperity
avatars provide for simple interaction
with whomever you choose during your
metaverse interactions
there are however a few concerns with
the Advent of the metaverse users may be
diverted onto a street or guided into a
risky physical circumstance such as
robbery or mugging as AR technology
enters the picture businesses will need
to make advanced preparations to ensure
their AR and VR systems are not
exploited either internally by unethical
management looking to violate the
privacy of their co-workers and
subordinates or externally by hackers a
full metaverse where a lifelike
exchanges are feasible is still years
away despite the fact that the core
concept of being able to interact in a
virtual online environment has been
around for many years Microsoft
co-founder Bill Gates highlighted that
most people lack the VR goggles and
motion tracking gloves to precisely
record their emotions body language and
voice quality but according to Gates in
the next two to three years most online
meetings will switch from
two-dimensional Square rooms to the
metaverse a 3D environment where
participants interact with virtual
avatars so here's a question for you who
was the first artist to perform a
concert on the metaverse Travis Scott
daler Mendy or Justin Bieber give the
correct answer and your reasoning and
stand a chance to win an Amazon voucher
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section and we will provide
the answer next week we hope you found
this informative and helpful if you've
enjoyed this video a thumbs up would
really be appreciated
don't forget to subscribe to the simply
learn Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update on the latest
trending Technologies
[Music]
[Music]